thank you
[Music]
guys we got good news and bad news
what's the give us the good news bro you
like bad first yeah yeah what do you
want first good news for a shirt first
dude make the bad feel better what do
you want first oh that's a good idea not
bad first what did you want Pat okay
okay the bad news is that uh globally
male testosterone and fertility is down
like sperm why is that bad I heard about
that yo I heard of cell phones in your
pockets yo I heard that really [__] you
up it's the food that's the Andrew
huberman said get out of here you said
the food the food yeah what about the
food I mean
nutrients in the eagle eggs yeah the
eagle eggs some in your Eagle flowers or
Eagle Powers so preservatives that's the
main thing huh yeah and the chemicals
they're trying to preserve these nuts I
think the bad thing is we're getting
more and more [__] as a species though
I think we're less I thought you said
we're getting more [__] we are we are
okay
it's just going down we're getting more
[__] as a species that's no bueno we're
becoming more [__] we're not like as
men just getting more that's what I
thought vagina out there
we're turning into [__] [__] yeah
more senses interesting now how it works
we are getting pushy but we are also
getting pushed pretty cool but I don't
think that's true because if you're
[__] you're not getting [__] think
about all the jobs during our
grandparents and older like most of them
were doing labor manual labor yeah and
then testosterone is linked to heavy
lifting and things like that so then if
you're doing some man work out there
lifting [__] all day chop it would you
know what I mean like
coding aggressively you don't gotta be a
weightlifter you don't gotta [__] be
deadlifting a million are you picking up
controllers pushing back wow the
resistance dude that we just solved it
yeah you got to make a keyboard where
the keys are forcing itself up so
they're just
your fingers
baby if you want so you don't use your
fingers you have to like get a workout
every time
good news you guys want the upside to
this yeah what is the good news the good
news there's a lot of docile ass dudes
good news that might still be bad so
testosterone and sperm counts down but
the average dick size is up oh that's
wonderful how do they do these things I
don't know how is this a survey you just
have to have a clipboard stand in an
alley and go hey buddy come here is your
dick how big is your dick and he's like
oh dude yeah so can I see your dick
Studies by people who lied yeah or
whatever know it's like can I see your
dick and then you go okay now come and
then you count how much now come now you
count how much sperm is in there
the Cha-Cha Slide you just do things
when they say what if this is like in
partnership with like only fans and they
just send all those DM like shrimp dick
like hate on me type things all over
into this giant pool of data and
information so you see a bunch of penis
sizes okay shrimp ticks got bigger yeah
the app if the average shrimp didn't
gets a little bigger all dicks must be
bigger that's true oh
so you know like a relative yeah like
back in the day right like they would
talk about how tall someone is and then
they might have only been like five
eight or five ten or whatever like like
if you go to the mafia Museum like oh
like this guy was a was a hit man and
you're like I need and you read and he's
like five eight he towered over people
you're like but then now you're like you
gotta be like six feet or six two or
whatever right and maybe it's just with
relative bodies they're just getting
bigger yeah yeah yeah right there's more
food in these states maybe your Height's
getting bigger but our dicks barely
getting bigger but it's like actually it
looks like racially we're smaller just a
lot of people are getting that procedure
done no man [__] up you guys do you
guys want to know you're here at all
what's the point of having a bigger dick
if you ain't got no nuts do you want to
know that's true they've published what
they've published a global ranking of
dick size by country oh I see this dude
there's not one another absolutely yeah
yeah well I think when you've seen it
because you can't know this yeah
up every day
but you gotta measure it though I don't
like that when guys tell other people no
no no no they they Jack them off they
Jack them off and then at the last
moment they they pull a ruler out
so it's only in boners it's very
sciencey dude it's measured by boners
it's
erect's penises yeah it is it's boners
So like um
um you can tell by that country's
condoms too
oh Joby definitely checking out all the
condoms in every country's aisle but
there's so many people who buy like the
wrong size condoms just to look like
just for it to come off on purpose
exactly the things that I do I like all
responsible
spread up it's the comments in this
country baby it ain't me like I tried so
it's it's inside of you know
I travel to go to McDonald's
I want to travel and I visit every
single McDonald's and then the second
thing that I do is I buy condoms at
7-Eleven
at different countries who has the
biggest and who has the tightest
I don't hide it snug as fit I feel like
they're all the same oh except Vietnam
what why Vietnam it's what Vietnam
um it's a smaller size and I don't think
it was a small it was in English is it
skin tight on you and it was just Durex
it was the same brand yeah you want to
know let's start here in the in the kind
of the happier side then who do you
think is the number one biggest average
erect Madagascar nah it's not nice Kim
said it's the Congolese
he's actually it's actually not the
Congolese that's what he said he did he
said that when he was here and it was
really funny this is stereotypical
actually no I wouldn't say so I didn't I
didn't know this is the Germans
okay can I can I get a can I is it is it
white or black
I I don't it's neither
Brazil Espana
it's not Brazil no let me let me think
about it the funny thing is like I'm
just going through every [__]
cultural dick in my head right now to
see which one might be better go the
scientific route was it cold I'm trying
to see are they boxer wearing
[__] or boxer brief is it close
to the equator warm climate yeah trying
to think I think about it warmer
climates uh grow bigger penises like
Samoans or something it looks like it
looks like it is yeah guys don't that
don't wear underwear blue zones they
don't wear underwear I said Don't wear
underwear have big dicks because it's
stretching out I'm thinking it's just
stretching all the science in this room
man I think it's stretching and hanging
let me go for the facts
we were talking about sperm count and
then we're like nah let's just talk
about Dick sizes so the average uh is
this this average in this country Indian
is six
it's
6.93 inches is the average 6.9 that's
pretty that's pretty high man it's a
good time let's see
it starts
it starts with an e e it's Ecuador wow
damn Tom Segura yeah
wow I think he's Ecuadorian he's booking
their flight and then it's Cameroon at
6.56 Bolivia Sudan Haiti Senegal Gambia
Netherlands Cuba nothing they're tall
yeah Netherlands dudes are pretty tall
yeah if another netherlandian had an
average dick size that would look small
on them because they're six five yeah
yeah that's true that's true and then of
course the bottom 10 for the smallest oh
you look just at me bro because I want
you to feel this is
[Laughter]
hey I ate McDonald's I got my growth
hormones the bottom 10 are all Asian
countries
bro it makes sense everyone there's like
five two yeah what do you guys wait
in that in that in the Ken yeah all
right
the one with the highest at 4.54 inches
average is Singapore the highest of the
test the highest the highest of the
bottom ten he saw this articles that's
the highest and the bottom ten but
that's not the highest of the Asians is
it because there's lots of Asian
countries right what do you mean aren't
there more than 10 Asian countries yeah
but the bottom ten are all just happen
to be eight yeah yeah what about the
Mongolian penis it's not even in the
bottom Town that's what I'm saying it's
a bigger Asian yeah because Yao Ming
gotta have like [__] a ding dong
s
academic vernacular
I saw a lot of dicks in elementary
school because they would that my
friends would show me yeah when he was
in elementary school not when he was
substitute teaching
careful guys
we had to dress it she said what I
remember a couple had
um micro penises and they were tall so I
was like man you guys are really tall
but your dick's so smart they're all
kids yeah yo this kid got a micro penis
yo check it out come on
but we were also like fourth grade yeah
yeah but don't they say like there's no
like there's no marker for penis size
right like as far as if your guy doesn't
mean you're gonna have a giant dick and
vice versa I'll tell you what I got a
really good anecdotal data yeah what is
it and I've probably seen more penis
than anybody in here okay oh yeah are we
competing
I'm not bad in the military right and
it's like why am I supposed to say no in
the shower at the same time that's true
that's true yeah
and I will say you haven't seen them
hard
that's true that's true they there's
Growers and showers if they're soft if
they're soft it's bigger than your heart
then you have no hope oh yeah because
I've seen that at the spa yeah can we
say that again if they're hard I mean
they're soft it's bigger than your heart
then you have no hope already yeah
that's true I sold I saw this one guy
at the spa and he was you know there's
that little sleeping area at the spa
yeah and there's like a little area
that's kind of like a curb that you can
sit on yeah he was sitting like this and
his balls and dick was going down like
that it looked like poo poo was coming
out but it wasn't it was his big ass
dick
he was a brother
I'll tell you a novel from my anecdotal
data all the brothers
hey gotta have at least average at least
vaccine super tall white dudes yeah with
[__] like
in a front desk belt
I need help everybody help me I think
that I saw a big brother that looks like
like a football player brother yeah so
they're like I was at the gym
and he had a baby's pee pee a brother he
was a big brother oh I never seen that
dude that must be hard though if you're
a big giant black dude your penis is not
like average that's probably that's
that's probably the worst bro yeah I was
shocked I was like why me I've never
seen that actually but I trust you yeah
and
Asians I've seen all different sizes
Latinos I've seen all different sizes
too yeah but the one there was one guy a
lot of bushes this one guy his name was
Sage who's Sage I think he had the
biggest dick in our platoon
[Laughter]
and it was a
Chase everyone around in the shower oh
wait no did you guys measure it or did
he tell you no it honestly looked like
probably like this
when he's just running around and you
guys would do this and he thought it was
so funny like he literally was just like
running around like this that's crazy I
mean that is funny right like just the
dude with the biggest dick in the
platoon running around in the shower
chasing people everywhere and he like he
Gotta Wear boxes military shorts are
those silkies right sometimes we're
standing in formation and it was just
like
no and then the Drone start to be like
put that [__] back down put that dick
away private what is that Soldier
well I mean that makes sense because
sometimes you see a sometimes you see
like a four foot girl that has some
massive boobs and you're like why you're
so small yeah
so that I guess that makes sense yeah
seen it
a lot of boobs that I've seen in the
locker room yeah
all right number one smallish erect
penis in this study is Cambodia damn
and then it's time
Sri Lanka Hong Kong
and then Bangladesh Thailand Vietnam
Malaysia and then back to Nick Singapore
you got the biggest one dude you're
you're myself
three are not in the bottom ten
[Music]
foreign